[Music]
welcome everybody my dad my brother and
my uncle are also here how about that
we'll do that for hours it's a
good-looking group good-looking group
tonight stand it up here looking at the
audience you guys look great yeah you're
welcome
one person owning it thank you someone
noticed Jerry it's so weird to see all
the other this big group of people I
don't know how many are 200 oh yeah 650
I've never been good at estimates but
it's crazy to think of how many
different individuals are here right now
just to see of different beliefs
interests preferences like for example
some of you love cinnamon toast crunch
[Music]
that's fair I'll clap for that I love a
little sin toast some of you hate it
because it makes your teeth itch one guy
do Wendell some of you don't believe in
ghosts some of you are absolutely
certain you saw a translucent lady in a
wedding dress carrying her own head as
you walk through your for yet some of
you are really digging this monologue
some of you kind of tuned out at that
weird ghost parts here's my point we all
have different ways of being in this
world and that's what makes life an
adventure our world is like Lord of the
Rings there's lots of different groups
living lives in their different ways me
I'm a hobbit guy not literally I'm not
I'm not two hobbits stacked on top of
each other that joke bombed put on the
ring
[Laughter]
I'm a Sawbuck guy I love The Hobbit
lifestyle it speaks to me eating napping
drinking reading breakfast second
breakfast elevenses that's my kind of
people
I want to live on the side of a hill I
want to smoke a preposterously long
wooden pipe I want to jump up and down
on a bed with all my guy friends in slow
motion and have it not be weird just
mildly Hobbit erotic hobbits I really
had to push for a hobbit erotic to get
in the scrub
that's my group those are my people but
it doesn't but just because I'm a hobbit
doesn't mean I want everybody to be a
hobbit I don't want everybody to be the
same what is this the Village of the
Damned Nazi Germany Connecticut
welcome to Greenwich these are your
mandatory chinos moving forward you
shall be known as
Shep that's why I like Frodo Frodo
leaves the Shire and meets all these
other interesting groups but he doesn't
try to turn them into hobbits he enjoys
them for who they are that's what makes
it a great story and we're the same we
live in a magical world not with just
hobbits but we got wizards and elves
really look at the hipster that's our
Elf nimble leggings boots and they all
kind of look like Orlando Bloom the men
too I'm not trying to change anybody
like for example I'm not a football fan
but I don't go into a sports bar trying
to turn everybody into someone like me
like a who's the point they're not even
from the cities they're playing for know
that guy's a jerk that guy that Shire
talk I'm in football territory now and
football fans are are dwarves think
about it there's a lot of eating
drinking farting sometimes spontaneously
singing as a group so kick it with the
dwarves paint your face drink huge beers
Buffalo Wild Wings is there mines of
moria
if you haven't seen the films you might
want to just sit this one out what about
the new one in The Hobbit you know that
weird forest hobo that has wacky ideas
and bird in this here we have those
here too they're called conspiracy
theorists and I'm not knocking him I
love them some guys believe Atlantis was
a real place and aliens altered our DNA
thousands of years ago go for it
radagast the brown I'm not gonna roll my
eyes at you I'm gonna roll a joint with
you and get into it pick up the pan
flute and play some Dark Side of the
Moon you crazy crazy diamond we got all
the groups really really old people not
all old people but like the really
really old mean ones
that's our golem you don't believe me
you ever try and pry a Werther's
original from an old person they got
trolls we got internet trolls they got
Gandalf we got Hasidic Jews
they got orcs we got the Real Housewives
of Orange County
[Applause]
[Music]